AMY: Hi, everyone.
This is Amy, off camera this
time, happily, from App Engine
Developer Relations.
And today, we're chatting with
all of the App Engine PMs.
So this is a really great
opportunity for you guys to
ask them the difficult
questions, the questions we
all love, like when will such
and such be available on App
Engine, and all sorts of other
tricky and interesting
questions, anything
you can think of.
They love it.
And so we've opened up this
Hangout so that some of you
can join, up to nine additional
people, I believe.
And so we hope that some of you
will, and you can ask your
questions in person.
But what we're going to do
right now is have the PMs
introduce themselves briefly,
and then just take some
questions from the moderator.
And if you go to the posted
event for this on
developers.google.com.
You'll see a link to the
Moderator where you can add
more questions.
All right, so I'll hand the
microphone over to the PMs.
ANDREW: So hi, everyone.
My name's Andrew.
I'm a Product Manager on App
Engine from Sydney, Australia,
and my particular specialty is
the Python Runtime, so any
Python questions, feel
free to hit me up.
GREG: Hi, I'm Greg
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm the lead product manager on
Google App Engine out of--
well, today I'm in Sydney,
Australia, but in general, out
of San Francisco.
I pretty much do a little bit
of this and a little bit of
that, so I'll answer
the questions no
one else wants to.
CHRIS: How are you doing?
My name is Chris.
I'm also one of the product
managers for App Engine, and
as well as Greg, based out of
the Bay Area, San Francisco
office to be specific, but here
hanging out down under
with all the folks in Sydney,
which has been fantastic.
So jack of many trades, but
focusing on data store and
other API-related things, so
I'll take any questions that
you have on that.
All right, turn it over.
CHRISTINA: Hi, I'm Christina.
I also work out of the San
Francisco office, and I'm a
Product Manager on App Engine.
The things that I work on that
you probably care about are
the search API MapReduce
sockets, a couple other things
like Mail, and assorted
other things.
I think that's all I work on.
GREG: Should we start with some
questions from the Moderator?
AMY: Yes.
GREG: So, Chris?
CHRIS: Greg?
GREG: What's the easiest way
to move data between Data
Store and Cloud SQL?
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: Oh.
AMY: And as a prize for being
the first person to join the
Hangout before we go to the
Moderator questions, would you
like to ask any questions live,
or introduce yourself?
And don't feel like
you have to.
GREG: Not to put you
on the spot.
AMY: Yeah, we don't want
to put you on the spot.
GREG: And can you hear Amy?
[INAUDIBLE]
AMY: Unfortunately, you're
a little muted.
GREG: Oh Gene.
CHRIS: So Greg, you
were saying?
GREG: So I was wondering, what's
the easiest way to move
data between data store
and Cloud SQL?
CHRIS: So I think there's couple
ways of doing this.
One way might be to actually
do a backup from the data
store, and then read through the
data and do an import into
Cloud SQL, and you
can do that.
The format for doing the backup
is not proprietary, but
the documentation is still a bit
loose on that, so we'll be
tying that up in the
months to come.
But the other way to do it
where we've seen a lot of
people have success is to do
just a simple MapReduce over
your data storage [INAUDIBLE],
the ones that you want to
actually back up and import into
Cloud SQL, and then do
the mapping, the reducing, and
then pull it back into Cloud
SQL, and then you can do your
ad hoc queries and whatnot
from there.
So we really that's probably
the easiest way right now.
GREG: Sounds great.
Thanks.
CHRISTINA: [INAUDIBLE]
if you've looked at any of the
MapReduce into Big Query
samples, those would be a good
starting point for anything
that you want to do to MapReduce
into Cloud SQL.
GREG: All right.
Until Gene rejoins
us, let me--
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: Oh, Gene.
I feel like we didn't
even say anything to
drive you away so quickly.
CHRIS: Somebody email him.
GREG: Yeah.
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
There's a few people watching.
Invite them to please
join life.
GREG: Anyone who's watching,
please join us live.
Otherwise, we're just going to
keep on babbling, and you
don't want that.
I will continue with questions
from the Moderator until we
see your smiling faces pop up.
So there's a question
here that I will
ask, I guess, myself.
Let's say there are one billion
elements of a model.
Each of these one billion
elements share an index that
is sorted by a float.
If these one billion elements
each change the value of float
every approximately 10 seconds
diversely, can App
Engine handle it?
So it does feel like I'm back
interviewing for Google again,
in reading that question
to myself.
Well, I didn't read it to
myself at that point.
So we're actually going to hold
this question and talk to
Alfred, who is our tech
lead for Data Store.
You've probably seen him posting
on Stack Overflow in
the groups, that
sort of thing.
He'll have a better
answer for it.
Essentially, it seems like it's
a question around, what's
the load that Data
Store can handle?
As I'm interpreting it, it's
was the load Data Store can
handle in terms of frequency
of changes
to individual elements.
So I think Alfred can do a
better job of answering that
than any of us could.
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: And we'll follow up on
the Moderator, that little
link where we post a response.
CHRIS: Are users able to
update the Moderator
questions as well?
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: In case you can't hear Amy
anymore, the disembodied
voice that we keep on asking
questions of, who you probably--
those answers coming from
off screen, is Amy.
All right.
So let me ask the next question,
which is, Andrew,
can you describe some of the
security models that can be
used with Google App Engine?
ANDREW: So this is a good
question, actually, because I
think this is something--
I hope you can all hear me.
So this is a question, actually,
I think it's the
first question people
ask when they start
using Google App Engines.
I'm used to working with all
these different components,
say a LAMP stack, or with a
typical application server.
So how does it work
inside App Engine?
And of course the strict answer
to a question like this
is, it depends.
It depends what you're doing.
But the way a lot of App Engine
applications tend to
look, especially when you're
starting out, is you'll have
some HTTP request coming in from
the outside world, and
then you'll have some scripts
that will capture those
requests and handle them, and
then they will write some data
to a back end data store.
And in App Engine, the way
that's handled is you've got
two things to think about.
The first is, how do we
control what HTTP
requests are coming in?
Now, Christina, we have sockets
coming, so this will
change slightly, but for the
most part, most of the inbound
requests from the outside
world all
come in through HTTP.
So if you can control the HTTP
requests that are coming in,
then to a certain extent,
you can control how your
application is exposed
to the outside world.
So how do you handle
security on that?
And there's a few different
ways you can do that.
The first is, of course, you can
write security yourself.
You can have your own
login systems and
authentication systems.
But we also provide some
additional support if you want
to use either OpenID or Google
Accounts to help manage your
security, we actually make
that super easy to do.
We have a file in every App
Engine project called an
App.Yml file, that can define
where-- or in every Python and
Go project, I should say--
that will define explicitly how
HTTP requests get mapped
to a request handler.
And in that definition, you can
specify if that should be
restricted to users
who have logged in
via a Google account.
And then if you want, you can
restrict it even further, and
I believe you can restrict it
to the level of saying, only
users who have a Google account
and who are also an
administrator of the
App Engine Project.
And that's really useful when,
let's say you have a few
administration components to
your application that really,
you want to be able to be
accessible to a web browser,
but you don't want to be
accessible to any Joe who's
coming to your website.
So that's one way.
And then of course, there's the
Data Store itself and this
important application data
that you've protected.
So your application code can
get to that, of course.
Your users can't get to it
unless they're able to
indirectly via your
request handlers.
And then the only other level
of security, really, is who
can actually access your
application account?
Who can log in and view the
dashboards and the consoles
that you have access to?
And that, again, is something
where you can explicitly
whitelist end users.
So you define precisely which
users you want to have access
to your App Engine Console,
all of the monitoring
information that comes along
with your project, and any
data that you're storing.
That's a somewhat long-winded
answer, but hopefully it
touches on some of it.
CHRIS: To add to that a bit, so
Andrew, you had touched on
some of the services that we
have like Data Store, and
things like that, and those are
all multi-tenant services
that are sliced and diced based
on name spaces that are
completely secure, thus one
application can access other
application's data, which
is great, right?
Until you have a larger
application, that is in some
ways made up of logical
components, right--
a front end to handle mobile
requests, a front end to
handle web requests, a back end
to do a billing pipeline.
And so since we have a bunch of
product managers here, we
can go ahead and talk about one
of the things that we're
doing now, and we just kicked
off a kind of small, Trusted
Tester program, but one of the
things we're looking to do as
we go forward in the upcoming
months is to give developers
that have these large scale
applications a way to segment
their applications such that
you can have multiple
components.
We call them App
Engine Servers.
So real quickly, the hierarchy
now would be going forward,
App ID, server, then version,
then the instances of your
application.
And what you can do there,
then, is you can start to
break out your mobile front end,
your web front end, and
your billing pipeline into
multiple servers that can then
choose to access the same data
store, MEM cache, or you might
decide you want to close off
one of them so that your
billing pipeline can't
necessarily be accessed by
your web front end, because that
just doesn't necessarily
make sense.
And so we're taking that
multi-tenant approach and that
secure model we have today, and
looking to make it a bit
more flexible, but still
making sure that other
applications--
not servers within
an application--
still cannot access the
Data Store data.
So that's a little forward
thinking of where we're going.
GREG: Makes sense.
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: Yeah, I think we have
some people lives.
Do you guys have
some questions?
AMY: And if you want,
you can type them
into the Chat window.
GREG: If you want,
you can type them
into the Chat window.
CHRIS: I see someone
is typing.
GREG: Amy, could you read
what the question
is in there to us?
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: OK.
GREG: Oh, so he wants
the answer, OK.
So the short answer is, it
sounds like what you're asking
about is specifically around
Data Store and what's the rate
of operation for elements
that can be handled?
And I think Alfred, really, who
is our Tech Leader with
Data Store is the best person
to answer that question.
So we're going to get him to
put an answer together, and
we'll post it back to the
Moderator once he gets that
answer together.
AMY: Could you ask them them
both to check if they were
watching the broadcast
that that's muted?
I'm hearing a bit of an echo.
GREG: So Amy wanted me to check
with you guys that if
you're watching the
broadcast--
I think the echo just
went away--
just to make sure you might be
muted, so there's no feedback.
AMY: Yeah, mute the broadcast.
GREG: Mute the broadcast,
yeah.
CHRIS: So on the topic of the--
the follow-up there that
I wanted to mention, and now
we've got the person that
asked the question, definitely
a good idea to get Alfred to
take a look at this.
I think he's had some great
thoughts on it.
But it's interesting to note
that back at IO, we mentioned
that one of the stats that we
put up there was that we're
handling roughly two trillion
operations per month in the
Data Store.
And max and I had some fun and
went digging around, and we're
up to actually 2.5
trillion now.
So I think this talks
about a--
I think you and I did some math
in the QPS, but to give
you an aggregate view of what
we're doing, 2.5 trillion is
no small number.
So we'll get an answer back to
you, but I just wanted to
throw out that data
point as well.
GREG: Sounds good.
So unless there are additional
questions from the people on
the Hangout, why don't I go to
the next one off the top of
the list, which is, when EU
Hosting for App Engine Apps
initially becomes available to
non-premier customers, will
all of the same services be
available locally, or are
there some services that
will still need
to round trip EU-US-EU?
Chris?
CHRIS: So we are actively
rolling out the support to
non-Premiere.
We look for that to hopefully
land in the next few months.
And in terms of the services
that are available, to the
best of my knowledge, all the
services that are available
today for US-based applications
will be available
in the EU as well and
will not round trip.
The whole idea there is that you
typically look to host in
other regions for two reasons,
and potentially more, but the
first that spring to mind are
latency, and then for some,
they want to control where their
data is stored, which
means that it's not just storage
at rest, it's where
it's funneling through
the system.
So it's very important that it
all stays housed within that
data center.
And so yes, all those services
will be available, and there
will be no round tripping
back to the US.
GREG: So the next question, and
Amy will interrupt me if
somebody in the Hangout
has a question--
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: Oh, excellent.
AMY: I asked if they wanted
to introduce themselves.
AUDIENCE: Yes, so
I'm [? Kahn. ?]
I have an App for your--
GREG: Is this [? Kahn Soro. ?]
AUDIENCE: It is.
GREG: Ah.
Hi.
I believe we've emailed in the
discussion groups before and
that sort of thing.
I recognize your name.
AUDIENCE: --Facebook platform
is on App Engine, currently
working on something new.
AMY: And we just got someone
else to join.
Olivier.
GREG: Fantastic.
Hi, Olivier,
CHRIS: So was there a question,
or [INAUDIBLE]?
AMY: He's just introducing
himself.
GREG: OK, great.
Great.
Fantastic.
So I'll continue on this next
question, and we'll keep an
eye on the live Hangout.
So with the growing popularity
of Go, are we likely see a
greater allocation of resources
to the Runtime?
As a Go enthusiast, what
can I do to help
speed up this process?
Christina, do you want to?
I can answer, but you haven't
answered a question yet.
CHRISTINA: Sure.
So the Go Runtime is definitely
gaining some momentum.
We don't have any specific
numbers to share with you
today, but we've seen some
pretty good adoption of it.
We are actively adding
features.
The Go team is actively adding a
bunch of features that we're
working on.
There are a couple that aren't
quite ready for us to announce
yet, but that should
be coming soon.
And I think if you want to
actually contribute to Go,
there's an active community
externally, as well as
internally, working on Go, and
so I think there are a number
of things that are actually
external that you want to
contribute, you can.
But that's another thing we'll
have to go check around with
the Eng team and come up with
any specific suggestions, and
we'll put them back
on the Moderator.
GREG: The good news is while
we're in Sydney, we sit right
next to the Go team, who is all
sitting down here, and so
we'll just go downstairs and
ask them after this.
ANDREW: Go is getting super
popular inside Google as well,
which is always an
encouraging sign.
GREG: Agreed, agreed.
Any new questions on
the live feed?
All right.
MapReduce jobs that take more
than one hour fail to save to
Google Cloud Storage with
a File Not Open error.
I'm using the [INAUDIBLE]
workaround, but is there
any way to make it
work with Cloud Storage?
Christina?
CHRISTINA: So the question is
around MapReduce stability and
things taking longer and
having problems.
So we are actively working on
improving the stability of
sort of the Files API, which
is how we actually talk to
Google Cloud Storage, and making
that a bit more robust.
Intermittent failures I think
right now, we're at a state
where if something goes wrong
there, it's really tough to
figure out what went wrong.
And one of the nice things about
an experimental API is
that we actually are still
working on and improving it.
So definitely look for some
improvements to that coming
soon, hopefully in either our
next release or the release
after that.
And you should see both some
transparent stability
improvements, as well as some
usability improvements to the
API that will make
those things last
a little bit better.
If you could actually post your
App ID either to me or to
someone else, we can actually
take a look at your specific
case and see if there
is something we
can do in the meantime.
Everyone can find my email on
the groups, or you can feel
free to post on the Moderator,
or to send it to Amy, and we
can have a look.
CHRIS: So I think it's actually
worth noting, too,
how seriously we take this.
Because whether you know or not,
under the hood, there's a
lot of other things actually
use our MapReduce framework
and APIs, as well as the file
system APIs, or the files API.
So case in point, something
that's near and dear to my
heart, so we have a backup and
restore mechanism that's in
experimental as well
right now.
And I really, really would like
to push that across the
finish line to GA, but one of
the things that's happening is
that since it does rely on the
files API, then we're looking
for stability there, and it kind
of works its way up the
chain, there's certain
dependencies.
And so when you notice these
dependencies, it becomes very
clear what you need to do.
And so like Christine has said,
we're looking actively
for hopefully in 1.74 or 1.75
that we have an update to the
Files API, and then from there,
we can start to see how
things shake out and backup and
restore goes to GA soon
afterwards.
And so it's kind of like
dominoes falling in a good
way, actually.
GREG: All right.
AMY: So we have a question from
the Chat, that actually,
you addressed earlier, but
you can address again.
Someone online now.
What is the easiest way to move
data between Data Store
and Cloud SQL?
GREG: Ah.
So from the online Hangout,
there's a reiteration of the
question of the easiest way to
move data between Data Store
and Cloud SQL.
Chris?
CHRIS: Yeah, so to reiterate,
I had mentioned backup and
restore, backing it up and
then reading the file and
importing into Cloud
SQL as one way.
But really mentioned that the
way we're seeing success with
users, the way that we're seeing
people be successful is
what I should say is to actually
do a MapReduce over
your Data Store, pick the
[INAUDIBLE] that you want, do
a map, do a reduce, and then
import into Cloud SQL, and
that seems to be working
quite well.
GREG: All right.
Thanks, Chris.
So I'm going to keep on waiting
for Amy to share any
new questions that come up.
AMY: [? Kahn ?] has asked a
question on the Moderator
[INAUDIBLE].
GREG: Ah, yes.
OK, well I see the question,
and let me do that one that
immediately.
Is the Premiere account
creation any simpler?
Last time I checked, it was
a must-be to be a company.
What kind of documents
are required to
create a Premiere account?
Can any company in any country
create a Premier account?
Why don't I take that one?
So the Premiere account
creation, it's gotten faster
because we have more people
working on it.
The main reason that somebody
must be a company is we
actually have to do a credit
check because of, essentially,
the way Premiere accounts work
and the way we open up the
services, essentially, Google
does a credit check on the
company first in order to ensure
that we can open up a
Premiere account to
you, which is why
incorporation is necessary.
In terms of the documentation
required, that's a great
question for our Sales Team.
We'll ping those guys to give
details around the specific
documentation that
they'll require.
And in terms of, can any company
in any country create
a Premiere account?
There's a large number
of countries you can.
There are some exceptions to
that, and I think we can also
get that from the Sales
Team to post, what
are the list of countries?
On some of the countries, we
can do essentially local
contracts with you in that
country, and then there's
other countries where
essentially, you would sign a
US contract, or a contract
for another country.
So we don't have contracts for
every single country, but for
most countries, we'll sign a
contract, either a US or the
countries that we do
offer for you.
But again, this is another one
where we'll go to the Sales
team, and we'll get from them
the list of documents that
you'll need.
And as I said, the good news is
we have more people working
on this now.
We have a larger team working
on the Premiere accounts,
which is good news.
We're growing.
But it also means you get much
faster responses in terms of
creating Premiere accounts.
I know early on, we were flooded
with requests, and so
it took a little while to get
those requests processed.
CHRIS: It's kind of worth noting
there too, it's not
only that we are ramping up
the team that actually
on-boards premium customers,
which Greg's definitely right.
We're actually ramping up
quickly the team that handles
the support requests as well.
So I've personally seen that
team grow from a handful to
many, many folks that we have
going right now, and it's
working out pretty well.
So I like the progress we're
making, all the way from the
on-boarding to how
we handle support
requests once you're there.
GREG: Are there new questions?
AMY: So, [? tons of ?]
useful information.
And as you mentioned, it
would be great if we
can find this online.
We can update the Moderator.
GREG: We'll update the
Moderator, and I'll also talk
to the Sales team about updating
our website to
include this information, so
you don't have to track us
down in Hangouts
and Moderators.
I think that would probably be
the best thing to do, so I'll
talk to the Sales team
about getting that.
And we'll update the Moderator,
but [? Kahn, ?]
feel free to reach out to
me as well about it.
I think you probably have
my email address.
All right.
So let's see, another
new question.
I'm just making sure I'm getting
all these questions.
How can we apply for the
Trusted Tester Program?
It was just voted up
as I'm reading it.
How can we apply for the Trusted
Tester Program for
segmenting an application into
multiple deployments?
This would be extremely
useful to the
application we're building.
This is the one you had
just mentioned.
CHRIS: Yeah, so this is the
App Engine Servers feature
that I just mentioned.
So it's a very limited program
right now, because we really
just got it out the door.
So look for an update to the
Groups that I'll send around,
probably within the next
month, I believe.
We will reach out and grow it
from the small group to a
larger group.
That's kind of the life cycle we
have, start out small, get
bigger, and then we'll
eventually get to
experimental, and then
finally to GA.
So look for an update from me.
GREG: If you're interested right
now, though, I think
just let us know your contact
information, and Chris will
track that, and we'll add you to
the list once that goes up.
CHRIS: Can they--
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS: That's a very
good point.
If you just email Amy, I'll
reach out to you, and we can
get things started.
GREG: Any other questions?
All right.
Then the last question, I think
the last new question
I'm seeing in the Moderator
right now--
wait.
Here's another new one.
So let's do them in order.
Is there any way to make a
Python New Relic agent work on
App Engine?
ANDREW: So there's a long
answer and a short
answer to that one.
The short answer,
unfortunately,
is no, at this stage.
Although it's not possible to
install the Python New Relic
Agent in your application today
as I understand it.
That being said, it would be
interesting to see if it could
be possible, given the we now
have outbound socket support.
So it's possibly something
that you could look into
adapting the New Relic
Agent to doing.
AMY: You might mention that
that's an [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW: So if anyone's on the
Trusted Tester Program and is
a New Relic fan, that would be
a really interesting project
to look at.
That being said, I don't believe
it's possible out of
the box at this point.
GREG: All right.
And talking to an SSL VIP of an
App Engine app from the UK,
the lower bound on when the
client hello of the initial
SSL handshake arrives is
much greater than an
EU-US-EU round trip.
It almost looks like there
might be two round trips
behind the scenes.
Is that expected?
So if I understand the
question, what you're
basically saying is, when you're
using SSL, it seems
like we're doing a round
trip for that.
Andrew, can you talk to this?
ANDREW: Only to say
that a latency--
so it sounds like what you're
saying here is that your
latency is almost twice as great
as going from the EU to
the US and back again,
which is surprising.
There is a little bit of routing
that goes on behind
the scenes, but I wouldn't
expect to see any hugely
appreciable latency increase
as a result.
So that's an interesting
question.
I think that's something we'll
have to put to the SSL team.
GREG: Yeah, I was going to say,
that actually sounds more
like a bug if that's
actually happening.
So we'll talk to the SSL team
about that, because that
shouldn't be the case.
Sorry, I'm going through this
list again on the Moderator.
[INAUDIBLE]
Go, MapReduce.
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: Ah, yes.
I found it very hard to work
my way around the minutely
quotas, especially URL
fetch minutely quota.
My support requests
were unresulted.
Is it any easier now to get
these minutely quotas
increased or removed?
CHRIS: So first and foremost,
if you can send us your
contact information, we can
follow up on that, so email
address plus App ID would
be fantastic.
If you're a Premiere customer,
you can go through the
Enterprise Support Portal to get
these bumped up as well.
GREG: I believe this is
[? Kahn, ?] who was asking
about also getting set up
as a Premiere account.
CHRIS: So in that case then, if
you can, send us your email
address and your App
ID or App IDs.
We'll follow up first on that,
and second of all, on where
the requests are going
to bump these.
Also, if you can, mention
where you
submitted the request.
I'm assuming it's from the Quota
Bump page that's live on
developers.googl
e.com/appengine, but if it was
somewhere else, please
let us know.
We'll see where those requests
are going and make sure that
they're funneling into the
correct queues so we can
handle them.
GREG: Next question.
It's funny, I see [? Kahn ?]
typing.
I like the asynchronous
communication.
AMY: And we just
had [INAUDIBLE]
GREG: Yeah.
Introductions can
be frightening.
So I think there's one
more question here.
And again, please continue
to add questions in.
What are the tools supported
to integrate business
intelligence into our apps?
I read that tools like Jasper
Reports or [? Bert ?] are not
supported on App Engine.
What are the alternatives to
generate reports and export
them into different formats,
PDF, et cetera?
Tools like Jasper Reports
or Bert are not
supported on App--
I was like, wow, that guy
sounds just like me.
It was me.
In terms of [INAUDIBLE].
Unless anyone else wants to
take it, I can take it.
CHRIS: Go for it.
GREG: Why don't I start,
and you can chime in.
So it kind of depends on what
exactly you're looking to do,
and it sounds like you're
looking to have PDF reports,
that sort of thing.
One of the things that some
people do is MapReduce.
MapReduce is a great way to
extract large amounts of
information and put it into
kind of a concise format.
The other thing you could do,
is we talked earlier about
moving Data Store data
into Cloud SQL.
One of the things you can do
with a MapReduce, and this is
actually a very useful thing
to do is rather than using
Cloud SQL necessarily to serve
all your data, you can do
daily MapReduces to extract
and consolidate the
information you want into Cloud
SQL, so then Cloud SQL
is essentially just a SQL
database that you're doing
queries against to get
this sort of ad hoc
information you want.
There's also a product called
BigQuery, which allows you to
essentially do ad hoc queries
on much larger databases, or
much larger sets
of information.
And again, you can do MapReduces
to take your Data
Store data and move
it into BigQuery.
And so I think between
MapReduce, Cloud SQL, and
BigQuery, those are sort of the
three best mechanisms to
do analytics.
Now, in terms of then turning
that into a PDF report, I
don't think we have--
excuse me?
CHRISTINA: Python
Image Library.
GREG: Oh, that's true,
that's true.
There's Python Image Library,
so you can generate it
yourself if you wanted to,
and turn it into a PDF.
CHRIS: Yeah.
I think I totally agree.
But to take one of your
thoughts and go
a little bit further.
So we have had a lot of success
with companies, gaming
companies and just general
Fortune 500 companies, doing
what Greg mentioned, which was
a MapReduce into Cloud SQL,
but more importantly, a
MapReduce into BigQuery.
In fact, we have some blog
posts talking about that,
we've got a Trusted Tester
program where we're actually
using Data Store backups to
import into BigQuery.
So those are ways to get your
data into BigQuery, and from
there, there's a very easy
SQL-like mechanism or language
you can use to query
your data.
But what I was going to add is
that there are third parties
out there that are tools vendors
that have actually
integrated with BigQuery to give
you that visualization.
And so really slick-looking
dashboards, things you would
expect to have doing BI, as
well as the ability to do
report generation, exporting
and things like that.
GREG: And if you really love App
Engine, you can build an
App Engine app to present
and display this sort of
information yourself as well.
But that's a great point.
The tools vendors out there that
work with BigQuery can
help you present information.
One of the things we really want
you to be able to do is
to do fast, ad hoc queries.
A lot of BI classically has been
running reports to take x
number of minutes, hours, or
days to run, to give you
information, and I think one of
things we're really pushing
for BigQuery to be able to not
have to have these static
reports that take a long time
to run, and then you end up
having them, so you run them
daily or that sort of thing,
but really being able to do the
type of ad hoc analysis
that you need to, in order to
understand what's going on in
your business.
CHRIS: You should be able to
find those technologies at
cloud.google.com/partners, I
believe, is where I looked
last night.
So take a look there, and then
I'm sure on BigQuery's main
page, they link to
it somewhere.
AMY: And also the Google
Developers Google Plus page
has lots of information.
GREG: So Amy was saying, the
Google Developers' Google Plus
page is a great source
of information.
AMY: Cloud.
GREG: Cloud.
The Cloud page on G+.
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: That's a mouthful.
Let's see.
I don't think any new questions
have come in.
Oh, is there one online?
AMY: Yes.
GREG: Excellent.
AMY: Sebastian has joined
us, he had some of
the questions that--
GREG: Sebastian.
Hey!
AMY: Please introduce
yourself.
SEBASTIAN: I'm Sebastian.
I'm from Argentina.
I run a small development
company called [INAUDIBLE],
like Developers Argentina, and
we do a lot of [INAUDIBLE].
I have in my dashboard 44 apps,
so I had to [INAUDIBLE]
the ones that I have.
[INAUDIBLE]
take some time to get to that.
I made two questions.
One was about MapReduce.
The issue I think I'm having
is that I'm using the
MapReduce [INAUDIBLE] to copy
the data from a large database
in Data Store to be queried to
do analytics for the marketing
team of one of the clients we
have, and it's taking more
than one hour, [INAUDIBLE]
launching more than
100 charts.
So I cannot launch more charts
to make it shorter.
And what I think is happening is
that the access token that
gets the library to talk with
the cloud storage gets
invalidated in one hour, so I
guess it's something around
that thing.
The other question I make was
about [INAUDIBLE], which I
love for when I'm using Amazon
And I was talking with one of
the guys, that brought
[INAUDIBLE]
and I think he told me that he
tried to make it work on the
App Engine, and the issue was
that he wasn't able to launch
a background thread to
contact New Relic.
So I don't know if someone has
tried it after the Python 2.7
was released, and if anybody was
able to make [INAUDIBLE]
to contact New Relic after the
request has been completed?
GREG: So I guess, Christina,
do you
want to take the MapReduce?
CHRISTINA: So for the MapReduce
one, I actually
suspect that you're correct,
that your token is being
invalidated after 15 minutes,
and then, you can't actually
access Google Cloud Storage.
It would be really helpful if
you could send us your App ID,
and we can take a look and see
if there are a couple of
things that we can do.
We're looking at adding some
functionally, both to
[? files ?]
API and to MapReduce, in terms
of improving the shuffler, and
seeing it if either of those
would potentially just solve
the problem immediately
in the meantime.
But I think that's
probably the best
way for us to proceed.
I don't think we can do
much more without
more technical detail.
GREG: Yes.
Send us your App ID, and
then we'll look into it
specifically, to debug that
problem for you, because it
probably means other people are
running and doing exactly
the same thing.
And then in terms of--
SEBASTIAN: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: You're welcome.
And then in terms of
New Relic, Andrew
mentioned this earlier.
I think there's probably
two problems.
One is being able to-- because
I do believe New Relic uses a
non-HTTP protocol,
I should say.
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: No.
It probably doesn't, but it
probably does have to connect
to the New Relic server, and so
I think you would have to
do that with the new
sockets API.
And even then the other aspect
is just, as you mentioned,
being able to spawn off a
new thread to run in the
background to do that.
So I don't New Relic well
enough to know, but my
suspicion is that could be
a challenge, as well.
ANDREW: It might be something
you could do with back ends.
Again, it would be something I
think we'd have to look into
and you'd have to try out,
but certainly, you'd want
somewhere where you've got a
stable, long-running process
that controls sockets.
CHRIS: Sebastian, did you
mention that you had been in
contact with one of
the team members?
SEBASTIAN: Yes.
ANDREW: Actually, Sebastian
has put his answer in the
[INAUDIBLE]
GREG: Fantastic.
So you've been in contact with
one of the New Relic team
members, or one of the App
Engine team members?
SEBASTIAN: Yes.
No, New Relic.
GREG: New Relic?
Ah.
So I think if they tried it out,
you can close the loop
between us and them, and we'd
talk to them about it too, to
see if we can get it
working with them.
I know someone on our team has
talked to New Relic before,
but even so, let's connect up
and we can see if we can get
it working.
CHRIS: I've talked to them
several times on the Java
side, so I don't claim to know
what's going on on the Python
side, but we have
talked to them.
We think they have some
fantastic technology.
The Java side has its own set of
problems in terms of class
rewriting, [? byte code ?]
rewriting, some invasive stuff
that we'd love to work around,
but we can try to close the loop
between your contacts or
our contacts, try to figure
out what's going on.
SEBASTIAN: Great.
Thank you.
GREG: Absolutely.
Thank you for using App
Engine in Argentina.
I don't see any other questions
on the Moderator.
CHRIS: Do we just start asking
each other random questions
about App Engine?
I'm kidding.
CHRIS: Look, he's got his--
GREG: Yeah, plushie!
CHRIS: That's fantastic.
GREG: I think I've got to go
down, visit Argentina.
I think that's what it seems
like, we all need to make a
trip down to Argentina.
SEBASTIAN: You will
be welcome.
GREG: Excellent.
SEBASTIAN: I got this
one from [? Ikay. ?]
GREG: Sorry, say that again.
SEBASTIAN: I got this
one from [? Ikay, ?]
I think is his name.
GREG: Oh, Ekai, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
SEBASTIAN: Ekai, sorry.
AMY: OK, why don't you ask if
anyone watching this to jump
in for last minute
live questions.
GREG: And if anyone wants to
jump in for a last minute live
question, let me know.
And did I see [? Kahn ?] asking
a question of where did
he get the plushie?
We might be able to hook
[? Kahn ?] up with a plushie.
I think, contact Amy with
your info, and we'll
see what we can do.
CHRIS: She's now going to
get 10,000 requests.
GREG: Well, I mean, if other
people joined the Hangout,
then they too could have--
AMY: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG: Yeah, exactly.
CHRIS: Use the coupon code.
GREG: So unless there's any
more live questions that
people wanted to ask, and I
don't see anything else on the
Moderator--
I think we'll say our Hangout
has been hung out.
CHRIS: Has been hung out, yes.
It was quite pleasant.
This was great.
GREG: Yeah, yeah.
Thank you very much.
Because the Product Management
Team is split between Sydney
and San Francisco, we don't all
get to see each other all
the time, so it's always great
when we're together in one
room and can chat.
CHRIS: Yeah, definitely.
All right.
ANDREW: Fantastic, guys.
Thank you.
GREG: See you guys, thanks.